foreign
question comes from Janet in Rhode
Island she asks my husband and I we're
65 years old we're traveling nurses and
we are paid we have paid housing
stipends we're debt free we own a house
worth 750 000 in the country on five
acres of land next to our daughter and
her family we've got eight hundred
thousand in retirement accounts and 200
000 in cash my son just left the
ministry and therefore has no savings
and owns no real estate he's renting our
house and wants to buy it he's got five
kids and it's a five bedroom house which
is too much for my husband and I how do
we sell the house to him we wanted to
sell it to him on contract and he would
have to get a loan and pay the estate
for what is left if we die the
property's in a trust now and we only
spend the summers in Iowa where the
house is located and we'll retire there
someday but we want a smaller house we
plan on building a small thousand dollar
square foot house on the property when
the prices come down love listening to
your show
signed Janet very cool well they've done
very well yeah got a net worth of almost
two million dollars it looks like yep
um well I I would not have
uh
payments owed
on the house if you want to
uh keep him from
uh let's get so convoluted
um
so what would I do
uh I don't believe in having debt with
anyone but for sure not with family
so what can we do we could give him the
house
that's possible uh check out the unified
estate tax credit you use up part of
your federal estate tax exemption to
avoid gift tax if you don't do this
properly you're gonna get your butt
taxed off over 300 Grand in taxes so you
need to see a Tax Advisor a tax attorney
an estate planning attorney and get this
done properly it's worth the money you
would spend with them the unified estate
tax credit so I would give them the
house if you want to
uh and then reduce their you know his
portion of the inheritance by the value
of the house at the time you give it to
him
um
if if you want to
further control it it's in a trust you
could
um
give him the house with a lean filed
against the house
with no payments and no interest
uh and that that lien is Forgiven at
death
yeah it's just it it guarantees that his
portion of the estate
goes to this house in other words
because here's what could happen Okay
let's say you just give it to him uh he
could go uh
get a divorce
and uh not likely I mean former Pastor
hopefully that's not going to happen but
it's happened before and
um then half of the value of that house
would have to go to her and he wouldn't
get a mortgage for 375 000 to pay her
out um
uh because those are marital assets
maybe maybe not because there's a gift
from Mom but who knows I mean I stranger
things have happened in divorce court
that were not just
um
Justice isn't always served in our court
system
um the um
so yeah I mean that would kind of keep
crap like that from happening or he
could just kind of lose his mind and
forget to be grateful and decide he
doesn't want to talk to anybody in the
family and he's already got your money
and all that and then he wants to go run
up and borrow uh six hundred thousand
dollar mortgage and go by six sports
cars in a uh and a boat you know or
whatever and uh now he's leveraged up
this house it's next door to your next
door to his sister your daughter in the
next door to you where you want to build
your 1 000 square foot retirement place
and all that so yeah I'm probably
putting a lien on it
that's the cleanest way that is
forgiving that is Forgiven out of the
estate and no payments and no interest
until then because he can't afford this
thing if they sell it to him for
whatever he can't pay payments on this
he can't well we don't think we don't
know what his income is well he hasn't
got any money he's got no savings coming
out of ministry we don't know what his
new job is and right but he's not in a
place to buy an 800 000 house tomorrow
it sounds unless you got a job making a
million dollars a year I don't know what
he's doing yeah but I I would probably
just give it to him with a lien on it
that's forgiven in the estate and who's
the right team you would have in place
state tax estate planning attorney could
do every bit of it okay and they can
help you with the unified estate tax you
can deal with the fact that it's in a
trust you can deal with every bit of it
on how to structure it but I would do
something along those lines because of
the things I just outlined yeah I don't
want payments
I don't want Thanksgiving dinner to
taste different because the borrower is
slave to the lender and you don't get
away with that
Christmas dinner in this case tastes
different right but um and you need to
talk this through with his sibling your
daughter lives next door if I understood
that right is that what she said yeah
yeah yeah yeah next door to our daughter
and her family and say okay you're
getting yours on our death and it will
have grown more than his his will grow
as he owns it yours is in Investments
and it will grow because she's got 800
000 over here yeah right and so you'll
get he's gotten some of his half if not
most of his half if not all of his half
and um just let her know everybody needs
to know everything and it all needs to
be done in a business-like methodology
in writing and you need to understand
what the downsides of all of it is
what's the worst thing that can happen
in some bizarre scenario and be willing
to accept that scenario before you go
forward that's that's part of managing
wealth is stewarding it well and knowing
here's what's going to happen to it
after I'm gone absolutely